Let's take a closer look at full consciousness. Now, psychologists use two
terms to describe it. First, do you remember when Susan asked if you've ever
been so involved in an activity that you've completely lost track of time?
Well, this is what psychologists call flow. Think of a sport, or a hobby, or
just some activity that you're really good at doing. Your attention becomes so
focused on this activity that time flies. Hours feel like minutes. You're so
engaged that time doesn't even matter. The second and last example of full
consciousness is mindfulness. This is when a person has a heightened sense of
awareness, and is focusing on the present. So if you're being mindful you're
actively paying attention to your immediate surroundings and what you're
thinking. Research has actually shown that practicing mindfulness techniques
can reduce stress levels and anxiety and it can actually be a really good
treatment for depression...